Christina is in Georgia hi Christina how
are you I'm good how are you doing
better than I deserve what's up good I
was going to get your opinion about us
downsizing our home my husband is a
pharmacist and he makes I have one
hundred and forty thousand a year and
brings home about a hundred and we still
have a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars of debt from his student loans
that we owe we have three children we
have just one that's just eight weeks
old and I stay at home with them so
we're just trying to see what we can do
to help free up some money money is
pretty tight at the end of each month
with his loans and our daughter actually
has like a severe milk allergy so her
formula is about four hundred dollars a
month so we're just trying to see what
would be best for our financial
situation how much debt do you have
other than your home his truck we still
owe about five thousand on it's our
monthly payment for it's a hundred and
seventy five dollars and how long has he
been on a pharmacy school he graduated
in 2012 and then he did a residents each
year after that and so when he came out
of school he had two hundred and forty
thousand in debt so we paid off 120 okay
so you've made some progress but just
not great yes and what's your hang
what's your homework
what's your homework um about two
hundred thousand and what do you all
want it 163 okay huh no I wouldn't
downsize it doesn't help you it doesn't
help you don't have enough equity to do
any good your payment is not it's not
what's killing you you guys are not
living on a detailed written budget that
you're sticking to you've been sloppy
yeah okay okay there's nothing wrong
with that it's just normal and I can
just hear it in the numbers okay I've
been doing this long I've been doing a
long time so I would instead of selling
my house and moving I would tighten up
my life and let's get on a detailed
written budget get the every dollar app
and download
for your phones and put it on the
desktop and the two of you sit down have
it come to Jesus meeting sit down tell
the kids there's a new word being
introduced to our house it's know and
we're not doing nothing
okay all were doing is getting that rid
are the rest of Daddy student loans and
that he's going to be working the extra
does he's gonna pick up gonna pick up a
pharmacy gig in the ER on the weekends
and raises income about forty or fifty
thousand bucks so we can get this mess
cleaned up okay my question to you you
have an I'm sorry let me stop you we
have an unpleasant two years ahead of
you that's better than an unpleasant
decade right exactly
yes another can I get him taken care of
yeah that's what I do I would lean into
this in a way that would just you know
that's gonna shake everything in your
life you're gonna live like no one else
but it'll put you in a position that you
can live and give like no one else it's
gonna be very unpleasant and you're
gonna you your kids are gonna go where's
daddy where's daddy and he's gonna be
working and it's not forever
he's gonna work like no one else so that
later even work like no one else and he
can pick and choose the stuff and all
that turn off the television at your
house when he's home and but he's gonna
be tired and you're gonna be tired
because you got four kids by yourself
you're gonna be a single mom for two
years but you can clean this mess up if
you do that but otherwise you're gonna
drag but along in front of the decade
and you're gonna be sitting right where
you are right now and the house selling
is not gonna help you if I thought I'd
clear it up I'd do it for you but it
just doesn't it doesn't move the needle